[Music]
i
ah
[Music]
y
[Music]  ]
[Music]
and
i
[Music]
the classic portion of the US
championship in the absolute and
women's branch has finished and in the absolute we already have a
result so I encourage you not to let anyone
know that you have to fight  still
for the tiebreaker it is samsung clan that
triumphs over fabiano caruana with an
incredible +6 to take the championship
we still have a lot of action here from
the san luis club since we have two
tiebreakers although more to be repeated and aníbal
but congratulations to the national champion sam
shankland  in the absolute branch here
we are with you direct from san
luís in what we still have a lot of
action
[Music]
ah
what's up friends how are you as always
a pleasure here to be with all of you
in the usa championship in the
tiebreakers that  await us on the day of  today
between the teacher any one and the
nazi teacher paikidze
in a live broadcast from the capital of
world chess saint louis missouri with
the great teacher alejandro ramírez and his
friend ivette garcía our last day
here we already have an extremely exciting tournament i
think  that the results
were very unexpected both in the
absolute branch and in the female branch not
at all incredible victory for
sunshine flan i think not many
would bet on a player outside the top
3 that we have here in the usa to win
the tournament but i did it convincingly
an incredible +6 is catapulted to 2700 and
part of the olympic team on behalf of
the united states olympic team
congratulations to the teacher to the great teacher
sancha clan and well he still awaits us
in the final stretch the tiebreakers we
have today between like and
nazi paikidze today we will meet
the
us national but well we have
here then the two players two
performances is enough  nte different yet and that
seems to me an incredible player still
very talented with many resources that
still needs to work on certain
aspects of her parents especially in
positions where the plan is not so clear
it seems to me that she failed a bit against jared
if she had some luck  win against
the loss yesterday of sabina irina cruz the
cross line game also a bit of
luck in winning but with a lot of
resources with a lot of momentum
and of course that was
enough to reach 8 points out of 11 there
are a lot of points it
will be good  playing against nazis in 15
that comes in a totally
different way in still not losing a
single game in the event and solid and
solid solid very very solid and good
as always thank each one of
you for being here with us
following the transmission  following this
day that we will have so incredible and
well let's see the format here of the
tiebreakers
we have in that part for the first
place of the champion  United States in the
women's category where we will have a
match of two rapid games of a type
of game of 25 minutes + 5 seconds of
delay it is important to tell you that it is not an
increase it is a delay it is a delay and
good in case of a tie in
these two  quick games we would go
straight to armageddon the pieces are
determined by lottery and white
well in this kind of game
white gets five minutes plus two seconds
increment and black gets four minutes
plus two seconds increment if
black draws
they are declared winners  and well
we have here this this impressive and to
the final stretch the final stretch here in
saint louis missouri and
how do you feel from alejandro excited
i have always seen him be a commentator on
the rapids more when everything is played there
is a difference of seven thousand dollars
between winning the  tiebreaker and losing it and
also of course all the prestige
that comes to being the clear national champion
of the USA the Olympic place does not  On the other
hand, we are the same, I am not
totally sure, but I think that if he
is also playing an Olympic place, they are the
same and I think I was born, he is already in,
but I am not totally sure, but
let's see the step they took to get
here to this tiebreaker first to the most
international nazi paikidze we have
nazi paikidze with eight points out of 11 in
the first round he wins against joe antigen and
fergie in the branch the numerator
draws against removes gordi in round number 3
he beats dor sader action and in round
number 4 he scores a  plus point against the
teacher chare beach in round number
draws against green a cruz round
number 6 draws against anif in and round
3 draws with 3 satoransky in round 8
wins against there I am going to correct you because
I think that is wrong
if you  he wins yes but it is repeated in round
number 8 nazi paikidze wins against sabina
foiso in round number 9 draws against the
same as in round number 10 he wins
before favor to change with a little
luck  and good luck in round number
11 draws against goals gianni and
we also have in the final stretch the road to the
end by the teacher any one
with only 15 years of age 8 points 8
points
the usa championship and begins by winning
the magnificent  tables with so many hugs to
my son are good results he beats
those of newsletters that had us a way
and he beats jennifer yuh he ties collage
and it's cut
and well these three trips in a row
really were where they catapulted her
or a lead of an entire point  up to a
certain point in the tournament the winner
is heading and beats angels and
beats irina cruz draws with massive there are
15 very solid in the ninth draw in the
tenth very solid against satoransky and the
mistake really yesterday losing against
sabina foi short that  let the
scope was born after an incredible
incredible performance and well let's see
if we have
the draw let's see the draw
up there where the players are
seeing who plays  first with white and
who plays first with black
let's see let's go directly to the
cameras where we will see the teachers already
starting starting in this final stretch
in the tiebreaks where we have annie
huang with the white pieces against nazi
paikidze with black in this that is so
exciting  so exciting the
tiebreakers no wow that they are playing
a national championship alejandro seven
thousand dollars difference in prizes
1500 each three thousand dollars 500 dollars every now and
then 70
already what they guaranteed 18 thousand dollars and
the winner of these is another 77 thousand
and it seems that  neither one will start with
then with the white pieces
what I have here are
images with white pieces against nazi
paikidze we expect a solid performance
from nasty in the first game a
very positional player they had a
duel in the championship of born with the
white pieces  but it is important to
remember where they have and managed to neutralize
without any problem
the initiative that tried to h  do nothing if
we remember that until then nothing
was more or less forced to win
because I had a whole point less than
courage and with two rounds to go, that is, I
had to win that game
yesterday because on the part of any we had a
fall against  sabina founder and well this
complicated everything and here the tiebreakers
but more exciting more exciting here
we are playing everyone is playing
the united states championship here
as always well excited in this
final stage and where we will already know the
national champion who is your favorite
alejandro  and I don't have a favorite but
let's say that if I had to throw towns
at someone it would be to me it hasn't seemed
like 15 years to the revelation of the event and
I would love for him to be part of the team
and well I was born he has already won one of
these tournaments and yes  of course she is an excellent
player
and to win convincingly here it seems
to me that she has really made an excellent turner
and that is very true and we took the
first round  like the
white pieces nazi paikidze with black pieces
and we have 4 knight efe 64 it is perhaps not
more or less expected from both of them
they will have already seen this in their
preparations with their respective
coaches he
has four fingers out of five
how good maybe  what I like in this way
many times in the opening is that he tries
to make a small surprise class in
rock in the main line here in
the knight of four are the moves that
are in full swing
but it is outside of this 5 that as you see
the  thani is not familiar with it because she is already
starting to think here and I don't improve it
much either but I do remember
that there is the idea of that 5, yes I hav
seen it before the idea that if you take on c5
immediately with the pawn I think
there is a  type of 44 and horse 4 up to
lady 5 at a certain point it is
quite a complex line if we take from porsche
5 of 4 more or less schalke what we have
done and go down 3
if I remember that this line exists but it
seems like six years ago  s months there is a fight
here for the 5-square yes and even
also in this position
we have a quick center
by black and also certain touches like
queens 5
5 which I cut into the center of black
here which will eventually be established
with five  and out of four it is one it is
dangerous certainly it is difficult for
white to finish your development but
in black they have changed and the
black bishop yes so you have to be very
careful with what the dark squares result
since white has a
pair of bishops
yes  you end up for the bishops matter not
many times here you are returning the pawn
but ending up in favorable developments
for white because I have a pair
of bishops this could become a
very open position and we have here on
the board
this changes of course this is going to change
the whole
the super risky base character for
both players two pedros less
now for I was born to eclipse but a
position where he has all the  development
has the whole center has the center the
development of the pieces let's see the
pieces by white they
don't have better hair in the h1 rook
if I don't know where the dynamism is going to be
against the static advantage alejandro
we have here a game that is  He will put
Pelosi and here in this way I still
imagine myself within his preparation because
he has not spent a second
let's remember that here he does not have an increase
what he has is delay so it is
different from the tournament where time was added
defending the point f 6 is
This position reminds me a lot of the
Laguna Bern variants where we
sacrifice that 7 and hh 7 which has
a very similar character to this type of
position
development of white this and a
few moves to finish it
efe 335 very interesting to
undermine the bishop to retreat and to take  in c5
if you are analyzing ok don't name what it is
called 5 I have 4 I will have a knight to see 4
and because of the pin here there is no 4
I always have to return the bishop
I think she played 5
m
we can even queen 4 I think it is
very interesting in this position she also
calls 4 to enter 102 to eat
simply here in natural the agro has
recovered a pawn which is good
news for her and she has not lost anything
of the dynamism on white has not done
anything to develop of course so there is
still a lot of compensation for the
pawn soon black's bishop
will come out either 65 and castling of
course on the long side
and well we have annie here on screen
one of 15 years the teacher any one against
nazi paikidze fighting for the
us championship and fighting for a promotion a
difference of 7 thousand dollars if we are going to
see what
the bishop of f1 is [Music] of 4,464 releasing here
I don't like  a lot of 4x4 seems normal to me
that is 4 I'm freeing but I don't know
I can't have something interesting to
eat on the go
I can bring file f5 castling long and it
opens column d
well it's normal but I don't know good
here there are many options there
are simply not four it seems more or less normal to me I
try to close the game if black wants to
open the game with a pawn from behind he has
to do it at this moment that in a
certain way it is not that simple he would
always almost always take from the
film  it seems like a natural move of 4 I
was born out of the preparation finally
tomás we are on time
we see that I was born it is a
very solid player move a player who is well
known for this
who is your favorite
just like she is your favorite who
is it for  let's get
it out well I don't know well everyone has
their favorites not yours in nazi
paikidze we are
divided here so hey so they pay me for
the tacos and we go here thinking
about what you must do to me thousands of
years
we have here on screen any  one with
22 minutes and I was born with 22 minutes and
they are really balanced let's remember
that the time control here is two
games two rapid games 25 more minutes
let's remember that it is  delay the delay is not an
increment how many seconds are the delay
5 seconds of delay that is, you have
those 5 seconds before making a
move before the clock starts running
is different from the increment so
where the time is accumulated
here they already take I was born their  time to play and
the reasons for that is a more or
less critical decision if she wants to end her
development with something like bishop 6
play with initiative on the
kingside touching each other playing rook 8
attacking down the go file if she wants
directly  take on the 3 take the
stress and see what I do with the queen something
like check here at 96 and open up
the position a bit but that often
lowers the bishops of course then you
also have to take some
consideration of that if white
who plays let's say the vice 3 knight f3
the rock that the end of 2 because for not
only will he have an extra pawn but the
bishops before,
even if white recovers his
underweight, black is not a bad mo  moment
to think
I would say that it is an excellent moment to
take into account
it seems to me that well the 4 is a
very natural move for me and
asks black as the question that I want him to
want to be dynamically clear the two
variants seem completely
healthy to me no bishops  6 leave the hair in
the center as an attack target or
take e3 but I know the two are very
different but both perfectly
playable we have here well and in one
who asks nazi paikidze
what do you want to do what is it  what does it
cost and what is going to be worth more in
this position your development appears to bishops
because in a certain way
after the variation that you say of
the 4 of x 3 bishop for from 3 to 5 check
I am forcing it to be a bishop of 296
black also has his things no bishop
f5 even on a knight 4 at some
point taking advantage of the fact that I have resources
like rook rook g4 then after
street 4 when defending the knight df
6 then the pair of  bishops
yes and the pawn then we are going to see
how this game turns out
who is thinking with
ian and wang with 22 minutes already with 19 minutes left how do you
feel alejandro excited
if it is going to be a good end to the tournament if i
I like that these tournaments are not determined
by some strange system I don't think they
go directly to the game to wish
one and that it ends up on the
board
yes well Alejandro well the truth and the
truth a national championship
cannot be decided by a tiebreaker  We see that
many many passes and if there is a lot of it, it is
a system on their part, it is not like
pujols or
cumulative or that type of system, it is
better to determine it on the board and
here we are thinking of annie huang with
white against nazi paikidze with black
in this first game  from
the us championship playoff if she doesn't
she's taking her time through the
whole tournament she's been a very
fast player and she's never really had
time and  n the whole event and
rather he has even made very
practical decisions throughout the whole game in the
whole tournament in regards to the
time that I think he keeps more than 6
is not a very subtle play let's say
6 queens with the idea of  rooks of 4 attacks
aquila
the h4 gesture and would attack the pawn not to
mention that the queen does not have either
as well as many clear squares in all
the moves because they seem more obvious he
guards 3 h 3 so he makes 3 for the idea
with the problems of  a square
etcetera seems a little more logical
because it allowed our to be the queen if he
didn't need it of course that perhaps
with the h3 pawn and the queen it would be very difficult
to attack on h4 that I can't
get to him as he attacked not also another
thing is that the bishop of f1 does not have a
little has a bishop of two because it can come out
at a certain moment but I would say that it is
difficult to imagine that this end is
played to a power that is not three
and it will take time because I do not see a
quick way after  After h3 to defend
the pawn on g2 that allows the bishop to develop
because I have constant pressure of
course, that's why I don't imagine that he
is finally a factor when one is
wondering if f 383 are moves
that seem more logical to me
because three and  four is
quite a serious threat and I don't see any other way to
avoid it yes of course after 3
or f3 we would have to be careful on
Black's part for a bird 4 try
then the development on the
queenside we could do 5 to 4  try to
start with these ideas on the
queenside no if a lot of elements were not on
6 too well white is
definitely not going to play well 4 the
next move no him what is going to be the
knight f3 try somehow to
defend the pawn  df de g2 huércal bishop
of 3 the short block and finish its
development black's problem
now is to find objectives
after bringing play I'm not going to put it
on the board but it
is to find objectives  you the idea at 5 to 4
is very natural against that structure
because it is less weak than it does 4
weak and it will allow me at some point
with pins 6 and either knight to 5 or
play let's say 13 8 and knight
somewhere and start pressing  a pawn of
this 4 that is already being
attacked to ni think more or less like me
and instead of h3
efe 3 which seemed to me a more
logical move since this knight of thought is going
to go to g3 nito they are connected  maybe
they have to be a little careful that
if at some point I play knight
2 that they don't play something like d3m I win a
time here against the knight if 3
leaves the strong square of 4 for the
knight of that 6 then yes it is  very
important to keep this in mind here
we could think about the plan that
we had already discussed with black on the part
of nací 15 as you mentioned playing against
white's structure or simply b6 and
continuing with black's development
I like more 5
to 5 is a little more natural  I would say 5
to 4 real  mind the black the white to play
three days a bit
like I told you no no no I don't understand
but at 5 and I don't want to leave 4
so for that I want to play 3
against 5 to make 4 b 4 but it
sounds like a  bit as risky of leaving
so many weaknesses with the name
finished developing could be
considered bolts are safe count
5 probably just have to
allow you to play me 4 i find the
knight h3c the most logical thing to play the
knight of f2 out of 3 or aeg 4 something
like bishop 6 for example knight
efe 2 to 4 and get to those types of
positions where again the pressure is
quite real but it is still the
pair of bishops and there is still no
plan that I say so they are going to win this
pawn  of f3
and well we have here live and direct
dear friends the tiebreaker for the US
championship in the final stretch
here of the women's category where
it is not necessary that I was considering it
extremely risky because it puts 3 it
is not going to  survive a lot but with a
fairly obvious plan not from this knight I want to
enter from 4 and then and give this
check on c2 completely devastated
even bishop 6 has also also pressing
the c4 plan of course the problem at
the moment
so let's say that 2  492 knight
of 4
but it is quite serious when it comes to tactics I
find myself for example so out of 4 people
I saw 4
the idea is that tactically if
I play bishop for 3
a knight must 3 attack and attack wins that
is a problem but if I play  when he signs 4
first and removes the queen let's say he
wants it because here vice 2 you
simply eat it you have to take it
even we give 2 even though he also takes
the queen seems very good to me and this ending is
despite losing and there are two pawns that
it is already  a lot and there is no
compensation on the part there is but not
for two pawns and the idea is that if the
film 4 intermediates and takes away the queen
anywhere after the end of three
knight three double one well I already
defended all the  s people all the
lares are attacking no then queen
efe two seems to me a very logical move
because it prepares that filters them mind 3
for since they protected 4 which is good
I am not sure how he prepares bishop of 4
surely it is a waiting move
because such  Once he goes 4 he has no
threat
and here probably after
manifesting something a little more subtle
like the film is 6
bishops 6 to pressure each other 4 rooks
13 1
3 if they repeat the knight of fours and
bishop for three knights of three I have
rooks  33
then but with another move order
give me faith 2 and nc on the board like
I say bishop 4 for bishop b4 it does
n't seem to work it seems like it just
won a pawn so I have to
probably play something like bishop
ezeiza something a little bit softer I
think  I was born really wants to play horse
of 4 as for that he played of 3 and if I
can't play here of 4 immediately
maybe I'm not so sure because julián of
three first babies we were for him
file was made to five as I was
mentioning variant any move if
he prepared the attack because the
direct three tells me I want to play
knight of four and once with a single
blow it is
better to prepare it as
five bishops commented 6
[Music]
we have an  ewan with 18 minutes against
nazi paikidze against 15 minutes
remember that the time control is
25 minutes with 5 seconds of delay five
seconds right five seconds of delay
five seconds of delay and we are
playing here the US women's championship
let's remember that we already have
we have absolute champion here of the
championship we had sanchez plan
with an incredible +66 alejandré yes
impressive what shankland did know
usually a performance and as an
urban family with five more than
enough to win the tournament at least
a tiebreaker but it doesn't always work
not always  it's enough he just
won family no but he also won son
jack and go with one more that is what
I like  i mean since sánchez
did his work also yes
impressive very good a +6 an
impressive +6 here of development and there it
goes by horse of 4 that seemed to us that it did not
work by bishop sees 4 to ivan film 4
he does it with some confidence  quickly
and they have and he tells them well then I want to see
no well tell me where you are where that
compensation is
yes
and we have it on the screen going up
after sign 4
we had we had to have two for
example what do I have to do mom of 82
then we would have seen
also  horses pigs no but lady for
pigs and from 94 to porsche 2 for 4 and
we had seen this position that I
have no problem I'm sure there
are 20 the others if I don't really see
any compensation for them something slight
there but it's not enough if nazi
paikidze already with 13 minutes on the clock and
any one with 17 minutes alejandro there is no
better use of time here dean and that at
this moment he puts himself in trouble seems to me like
a nazi that he has to play  stify the
compensation justify the compensation
for the two pawns and I don't see it here right
now I don't see this compensation
Alejandro we're already in the
final stretch in less than an
hour we'll know a good one plus 22 hours
we'll know who it's going to be  the
national champion of the usa with a
spectacular lathe 8 points out of 11
and go if alone more than 6
a play that in my opinion
if it does not do as much as the queen
elsewhere you can take the 3 is obvious and
forced more or less because yes  I don't take the
pawn I don't know what I'm doing file
6 again and I was born it creates threats that
seem more or less ghost to me because
again taking in here on c4 leaves me a
pin and the driver that one doesn't
then he asked me if I just
I develop jamaica game of two
basically you have to focus
and even then yes castling long for
example by black
yes but even already on horseback by four
eliminating the strong knight of 4 I don't see
the compensation  nowhere
do I have to take another edo bishop
I just don't see anywhere
four rooks usa you don't have too many
pieces that you have to remove
sometime from the file if we don't have
time to prevent b3
then it's taking pin two too much
the king in only six  now the
end itself four if this is the
current position that we see on the screen knight and
two is a very natural move
typical of the position that needs to come out
he develops me
and it is not difficult to calculate that in the
end by c4 he will never  Being a threat, I would be
very surprised if it is not played
as the obvious move that they do not take from
the knight, it is simply a saddle again
without making the one that has to
prove that some type of compensation has
here knight 2 made as I had said
gentlemen  we already have it on the
board and we see that pai kit is born
centering a certain pressure 5 minutes
away and 55 minutes
difference in time control dear
friends why  What they are asking us here
is 25 minutes with a 5-second
delay without a 5-second delay each time he
makes a move as long as we
had expected the knight is
threatening certain overdrafts that I
imagine that what he has just said is true,
although in  At this moment I don't even know
where the discovered ones are
because of the stress I always take as a queen
defining the bishop knight b3
I always have double 1
since they won't even have
long castling so the knight is not
threatening anything
if knight b3 I have a rook  1 still
defending from 3 let's say raise a bit
short myself to block shorts and
I want
and even if at last
and I get rid of threats but
castling long and short is possible
usually with a material advantage
one would like to just keep the
oxen in  the same
in the same sector of the game I would
consider, although I will be a little
strange, castling long with the idea that
towards the end by 0-4 I
finally remove the king ha  borrowed a
lot because I have to go higher
I would like to have the king in my hand
well it's not that later I have a g8 rook
if he was saying that he heard me a
specific plan like that you and janis
have an antenna it already happens as if almost
knight b3 what was it  what we were going to
see if in the end by 0-4
415 44 there is no overdraft because
I'm thinking the lady has to take the
flavor of the mind and here I imagine everything
fits the faithful
tomás de torre or whatever and receives one
and this  this end this position is even more
favorable for white than what we
were seeing because the police are already more
simplified and
white's initiative now he is not very sure he
is not playing the range of two or queens because of
the seven they are threats if we are already going  to the
current position bishop by c4 I imagine
that it fits by four more or less
forced they could 144 obviously
we do not have any screen we have it
on screen in this first game of the
tiebreaker for the us championship in
the category  female ory yes horse by
because he
has everything to win here 444
well let's wait and see how he takes the c4
nazi because he is not forced to take
everything the same yes
but anyway
[Music]
and I'm threatening towers events it
seems to me that better  best option take from
torrent i really like
annie's practical decision to return a worse
but have the king on the same flank as
your opponent thats another game this
allows me to be completely stable in
this position if thats very true but its
not looking  but if he takes 4
if I take c4 we don't have a rook of 4
no to me I have it for you as
we already have it here for 0-4 as we expected
well here he is thinking Nazis and take
with everything to retake with queen but but
after that I don't have  one less pawn the
bishop is superior to the knight and they hear
efe 6 very controlled and the problem of
king 18 is quite serious the truth was they
were seeing many variants
where now the queen and
white's rook coordinate a lot  or better than the
light black one here we have with 10 minutes
in the other by nazi paikidze
with 12 minutes of 114 it seems to me that
annie huang takes with rook as we
had seen it i am king of 191
instant there is no reason
why not  and these entries of queen 2 or
queen 7 are very dangerous difficult for
both
to play horseback is seven games
better than somewhere 5 7 of 7 of 7
7 a bit strange
and it works as the action plan does not work
because the rook is trapped yes
oda vapor so it entered through a 73 and the torus
is trapped
it can be removed here but 13 1
yes the same way for example given by a 7
I don't like it because I have a certain contract
after rook by g 2  at some
point it
is necessary that we have
and we are going to see what we have here
on the screen does not know if all because 22
I have drama at 8 check
77 suicidal
I have to do
but then what do I do but from 6
here I have to after giving up  7 yes
you have to have a game with a tower  because 2 to
have his wings to more than 7 obama 6
but it doesn't matter 6 is also suicidal
just those two medicine hairs
lower transition that is a beauty
similar to ours the functional way
in suicide I don't expect anyone less than
some kind of counterplay  no, that is
more and more lost for Nazi, it seems to me
that a fairly solid game on the
part of nigua, just waiting for it to be
born, will be thrown at him and that is precisely what he has
done, not with all these
moves sacrificing pawns when
all three maybe  little necessary in ago
that she is not known as an
attacking player and it shows me that
both yesterday against the collective Russian
and today that she is really an
attacking player no yes
positional totally two of them let's see
the clock yes  13 minutes against 8 a
substantial advantage here from here we
have it on screen 13 minutes 35
seconds to 8 minutes of nazi paikidze
8 minutes
when you're not lost well play the one
you can practically see  more interesting
is threatening provider rooks
even when physics doesn't
seem to me to be a problem of four either but
if nothing more than calculating here it seems
to me that there is no problem with check na
after queen to 8 as we have
mentioned roots 7 suicide later  from
at the end 7 I am killing on bishop of 6
I also have everything here after the end
of six bishops 7 also how do you
take control
yes black as he has a time
less I can never take on b2 because
I always have 91 and that was the  end of the
hackers of course and if it's wrong for
example 868 also the problem
then to the current position queen 8 already
on the board
66 black
yes no andrei under mates and sooner
than white if after eight
o'clock as it continues he takes out  how are you still here no
obviously black has nothing that
queen 8-7 or knight sees 8 are enough
to hire his services
is the same as surrendering but at
least let's say that if I were a
practical player  co and I have to win this game
problem losing the list 7 seems a
little more complicated than horse I see
guy investor field of 6 it seems
much easier to me to go to the
eibarresa hackers 7 at least here force the one
that finds the film is 7 of course
it seems that it is less logical that we say
something like say 6 or a row to 5 which
also seemed like a very good move and
bishop 7 destroys the position is that there
are no direct threats
from black if he takes two moves
basically if bishop 7 doesn't  it's such an
obvious move let's say
so maybe it's a
practical opportunity on the part of annie one who has a
lot of winning moves one imagines
the file of six queens five rook of six
even something subtle like king to one so
she just takes off the  tactical blows
there are some rooks e1 should also
win if there are many ideas that win
but but you have to choose one and
many times as there are six that win
and one chooses the seventh if the to  how
practical not if we have here on
screen the tiebreaker the tiebreaker by
the women's category of the US championship
we will know today the
champion the champion here who will
take 25 thousand dollars 25,000 dollars and 27 thousand
dollars of difference what  we are
playing here quite a long time not a lot
of money a lot of money
and apart from that the prestige is not the
champion of the usa if we are going to see what she is
thinking here they have the same thinking how she
finished off nazi paikidze you can remove the
king it is 7 it is  a slightly more
practical move because at least it forces
White to look for that that path that
path to glory this path that will already
lead to Black's mate using the
point and a point
would have to force him to win the
next game and  go to an armageddon
if the armageddon the armageddon that if
we get to this tiebreaker it would be five
minutes for black and
four minutes for white
in case of a tie c  with the black pieces well
here we would be seeing that
the whites would win and 45
[Music] a
lot of pressure this type of center has
been in some tiebreaker if the
armageddon three times and it is complicated it
is not like a lot of pressure a lot of pressure
above all and to reach a help
means  that the tournament was very long
the formal shoes and it seems to me
that one kind of runs out of energy and
armageddon always those games are
chaotic they are difficult to play and it's not over yet it
's already in the final straight not
after eleven rounds a  very
long tournament eleven rounds eleven
stressful rounds later
if here what are you spending your time making
sure there is a win if that
statue doesn't move a critical position
a critical moment if we get here nine
minutes for annie wang nine
minutes five seconds seven  minutes 11
seconds for nazi paikidze and we will see
here what is what he decides and
i want waiting for the bishop shot of 7
annihilating total bombshell in this
Alejandro's position profile is 7 he
is totally a winner he has that he doesn't have he
doesn't have to find whatever it is it is not the
only way
to play in this position and well
before continuing I would like to send a
greeting to all of you thank you for being
here with us accompanying us in this
day in these playoffs of
the usa championship thank you for being
here with us we send you a big
hug and well here we will be here
we will be
following this transmission
if we have enough thinking already a
few have to be thinking if you have
and I'm going to tell you you have eight minutes
thinking about  I think this position
is fine if that's a good time to
spend time if since she's
looking she
's looking for the final shot
she's coming back here she's smelling and
saying here's something here's a
shot here there must be something here I have
to win  and he is doing it looking for
alejandro how do you feel for being
here today as a spectator of
the performances  you good a city and simón
or here already
in the last part of the tournament
the tiebreaks are not always exciting they
are always beautiful the attention is overwhelming
really bad players in this case
the players as if you don't notice when
you see them but inside they are dying
basically nine the attention it is
incredible to know that all the
spectators are only watching his
game that the only one that matters come on we
already have something on the screen
at the end 555 that also seems to
sound many wheels that he wins yes but it
was not the most and let's see if I demand the  attack
with queen 7 which seems to me the most expensive
if it gives more than 7 quite logical there is already 9
717 for the rook touch by 77 of 8 they
can now be the king of ochoa and if I
think I can take 6 instead
and they simplified final with  two
more penalties maybe in a practical way
this is more than enough he
will always retire three years ago to defend me two
the rooks in the seventh exist a little
but it's not a big deal and yes  i made eight
that the only other play maybe x and i
have to find a win not in juice
by the way call seven queens and
before the current position deciding
then if he wants to play 18 or king of 878
let's see where is the win here
because  it feels like a king of 8 take times
with the bishop and then it came to the rook
you have to play then 20 8 it
is easy to take s 1 as the engine and this
king will never survive compared to
this
basic name the mistress always feels
state defense yes  yes after queens 65
maybe threatening more than five and everything
not here
five in five and that position is more
than lost nilsson rook star
queen 7 check and all three
nazi moves lose but he is saying
any less we give up  They
have the game for me which they keep some
chance some chance
we are already getting into trouble king of 8 ago
follows king of 8 and here I was thinking
if I could just enter at the end with 6
change queens n  or because it doesn't change the
queens
of the pieces if I like them I
like them it must be from Caracas it's simple but
many times a simplification like
the peace of mind that they never give me
weapons
because
I like this one better because if I don't  I know I
'm not sure which was better of the two
but here it comes to neither with the attack there they
go and it escapes at the moment there's
nothing that I'm going to make it obvious
go
ladies it could take 7 to destroy
this this advanced defender and  always bothering
and that's how alfredo's blind report moved,
nothing more
and wishes also seems like a move
because if not the fill efe two rooks of
two rooks of a machine are the idea I
like this coverage of the bishop because
on the second row 3 also than another
I also like the idea if bishops and
four at some point in time
all we have to do is analyze and it is
important I think that this 2
I think it would not work for the entire
edge 7
and we are going to see if what I am saying is
ci  Too late
that is
authors of an even stronger one of course it
is stronger because if you take it out and
take advantage of the quality it is not very hard
even then around 23
euros directly it is also a
threat
if with the other two babies these
simplifications are always very
dangerous for the two passed dogs
also any ending is lost
so here I combine the attack with the
defense
taking advantage of the extra material it is
giving us the win for white it seems
to me that so far apart from not
finding pins 7 a good technique
has two pawns  too much if you have two
weeks simply at some point you have
to change the pieces indicate the
pieces and go to an end
and well Alejandro how do you feel
we are already here in trouble
annie wants 5 minutes and in nazi paikidze
4 minutes already on the clock and we have
efe 6 efe 6 by nazi paikidze
here we can think tower of 2 and tower
of 127 since it is well located since it
defends position b  lanca in a
moment and he is looking here at the end of
f2 rook 2 and rook 1 not very strong
since 6 it seems to me that it is a move that
gives the king a little bit of field he
simply says I don't have an attack I
don't have threats but  well i'm still in the
game i still have the tower a
clear second row something i'm going to be able to threaten at
some point something i have here four
minutes 58 we have any one thinking
thinking carefully
alejandro or today we're going to
meet the usa champion in a few
hours  we already have results here double
fingers as we have already said and well at
least the first point should dance the
same I am not saying that the whole
tournament could still recover
I was born mostly steam from the
white courts but the first point almost
definitely goes to the player  from
california from southern california born
in california yes born in california
city and grew up in california i've been
all her life also even
speaks english with the accent of l  a girl from
los angeles
yes yes
yes well born raised american
totally
if they ask us here they ask us
if she was nationalized american no city
born here
yes i remember that there were several several
years ago a women's usa championship
where not a single person was born
in the  usa but now these days
have changed we have people like they have the
same we have people like jennifer yuh
we have people like magnifique all
the girls basically who are
growing up here is chess all of
them were born here the chubby girl
here is fat sabina
armenian and georgia
we also have  like several who were born
outside the country but we are no longer in the
literal days of all of them
because we have nash here on screen
and if he is not obviously suffering
with both of them but less and especially
the king of black now he is much more
weak sees in very nice white what he has
done here to completely cut off the
tower of the action and is going to bring the
own rook of 1 and black and is going to
press just going to collapse and
even the rook in which two sees is
isolated after bishop efe two
tornadoes totally isolated and that is why
he removes the rook by axis 77 which
is not that it helps either  there is not much
discovered obviously so it
seems like one it seems extremely obvious to me to
play a little fast to put the
pressure on it is important not to rush too
much time 1737 does this
and rook of six rooks of six seems to me
rook of 6 a threat
yes rook  say it seems like a very good
move to me
we make a bit of 6 I imagine that
I am threatening rook by efe 6 also
if possible by efe it is called bots
no no wait I am thinking oh bishop
h
if rook of 6 it seems to me 25 I don't see
how the other way around 695  I have am at 8 it is
also not so easy to move the queen
queen 8 establishes axis 1 locomotive
rather it lowers torje 1 directly there
which seems quite obvious to me very pretty
because it takes advantage of the fact that the tower has
come out of the cabbage  umna gy makes sense of
mine on screen i
have to keep out of the game and i
like
3 screen
is already here finalizing the position
we have an and one with three minutes 36
seconds against nazi with one minute 40
seconds and i want putting pressure on
him no  if possible,
eight means
try to keep the kingside alive in some way or another
I don't see why not
go in with the queen anyway
camacho 6 to play a rook of 8 on the
next move if they leave me like that there will be a
stain it seems to me  only logic
yes
if too much logic I would say damages 6
to put everything there yes that would be
everything everything totally damages 68
and I even like it a lot because already in h 6
another hour of a highly logical one
considering from a next move if they
give 85 it is also a  logical move
because the knight h
could be the one to fail, but the
rook of one by a, not one
among the actors completely withering,
fell from 77, it seems to me that there must already
be a hit
[Músi  ca]
give me 4
threatened for sure still escaping here
nd here 688 I like it because it touches the rook
n c4 and t
at is I like it if it likes it a lot and at a certa
n moment it already has a rook of six autho
s it is that certain moment because now t
e  rook of course the ouch lf2 short
also certain important queenside streets it
's almost impossible to
find a move without a
time stamp if you're running completely
out of devastating attacking moves
let's see let's see the clock
I worked 82 minutes 33 against 101 95 for
what he did
rook of 6 it seems to me that
we liked it until we also played the
film six times with film 6 at a
certain moment
78 backwards
4 2 and 6 are repeating the position once
and have several ways to win
especially as black is not threatening
anything
exactly the more than eight I return from more than
eight
but I would have to find a way of
life of 86 it seems to me withering
that another or another online I don't know good
anything big evident
na  it doesn't matter not long ago because he
won't be able to recover this time of course
it's not an increase let's remember that it's a delay
it's a delay it's 5 seconds of delay
5 that takes away time 5 more side at
least yes and maybe lady g8
threatens her  magic 8 na city more than 8
again yes if it is not so easy to play this
position knight b 8 by
black
and queens of 8 we have very logic entering
here in mind
knight who played and if he has 36 we have
talked but well
what  he did like this we can see each other do you like it on
screen or are we going to if we don't see it that way
so that the inspectors have nothing the
board not all that 5 what I'm
seeing the film in 4 other
I really like the white position very
tight the black is here  very tight it
is so so
and this is going to be a double attack of six
when the queen
four of six gives up and is coming out
then on the last move
14 1 was the last move and with that she
wins just like in the first
tiebreak game  I remember that we have
we now have about ten minutes of
rest for the players and we will be
with you then in the ten minutes
yes with the second game where you have to
win if i was born beijing is obliged to
win live
because if not it would be crowned as
the national champion some  draw is
all that a draw needs is all that
any one needs with black nazi
paikidze with white don't miss
it see you in 10 minutes 10 minutes
the second game of the first part
of the tiebreak in case there is a
victory by nazi  paikidze we would
go armageddon
[Music]
hello
because the wind pushes them on the shore
daddy because the sky is blue
because the sky is blue because it reflects
the light of the sea
for you but it has to be an
audio sacrifice like this for 8-7
followed by the horse
g  5 de mache 5
more and more boys are going to play
chess this is also going to lead to them
asking you more questions and they will surely
want to answer them in
essential continuous training  24 we are going to help you
to know how to reason how to think
in chess and so you can help your
kid I hope you have fun and
I really wait for you in 624
[Music]
[  Music]
and
[Music]
[Music  ]
ee
[Music]
ah
what's up folks here we are back at
the us championship on tiebreaks
in game 2 of  the tiebreakers
to meet the national champion of the
united states in a
live broadcast from the city of saint louis
missouri the capital of world chess
with the comments of the grandmaster
alejandro ramírez and his friend ivette
garcía as always well a pleasure of course
and we are  here already in what is going to be the
uag the second game the
victory tiebreaker of an equal in the p  first
game we are going to see the
crucial moments the shocking moments that
we had there in this game when a
very aggressive way of playing
here I was born with the black pieces I am
surprised that they have launched like that and
the shot does not work and we are going to  Seeing this
position
I think that's where he got into the most
trouble starting with which move 4
I think we were looking at these options
of quick horn bishops 6
or taking on 3
if he would have taken on 3 here since at the
end of 296 I think  black has
compensation I can move the bishop here you
have told me the move bishop f5 I like it a
lot caval 434 they are ideas until
castling long but I think the breath
is not good if it is more than six not
like it lacks subtlety then
I think it was a  error no a
rather important error on the part of nací
here the bad moves begin because it
allows this effective move
the white position is more or less consolidated it
allows the queen to return to the dside  e
queen and this move of three tactically
fails because the only idea of three is going to be
to put the knight in four yes and attac
in c-2 damm efe two pairs are excel
ent moves because tactically note
hat after the knight of four signs
four  healthy a very
important intermediate queen at 66 they
take from 3 and there is simply no
compensation for hector and I love
this decision after gentlemen to
return a pawn with the long roque and
arrive at this resulting position
where they did return my pawns but now
the advantage  white is overwhelming and
I have one of the lighter bolts she
is more than two
now 7 simply brutal threats
queen a 8 was the end in b 4 is very well
located where she always restricts
black's position yes that is the truth to
me  Danny loved the way of playing,
calm, dynamic, active,
and well, we already have the start of the
second game of the second game
here of the rapids of the rapids of the
championship  or female
and we already have here on screen a knight
f3 by nazi paikidze
from nazi paikidze 6-3 knight f6 bishop and
g2 and 5 let's see if we have here
we have 25 minutes 25 minutes for both
both players remember that the control
of  time is 25 minutes plus five
seconds of delay delay is not
an increase
one waiting and one Catalan from
the package but we are going to see that the
Catalan does not do four out of four things
in this tournament
I am a bit surprised by the decision
because again  to those who already need that nobody
is not a player of this type of thing, not
of course 6 and there we even have to take a
lot of likes because we can see if the
whole board is here then on
behalf of ali one put the many
ways to play against  of the
indian attack of kingdom r with the fast b6
as well as I said many ways to play it is
5 at some point from white
it is going to be more than 7 pressure
on 5 from black with a
May contract  7 the most efficient
game is always focused
on black's part let's see here that
we will have a game because
nazi paikidze has to win to
try to go to the tiebreakers
alejandro to the tiebreakers
we have to win nazi
paikidze
has to win and let's remember that the
time control is 25 minutes plus
five and by law that it is not an increase it
is by law it is delays and they were grams of
the possible plans here for white
as I was mentioning five there are
times where you can see the idea of five horse
here double of  one and there are actually two hours
of playing it not with knight f1
h4 go for kingside attack
which is one of the many
reasons why here instead of v6 you
can play castling but sometimes it is more
flexible  because sometimes the king does not want to
be on the kingside 2007 the city
castling long many times you see and c4
[Music]
there is no option rook 1 and more than 7
calls it simple it seems to me if we give 7
dame dam  e dos keeps still live
is well known and known from the film 7
almost forced
or also if we know and as I say it is
black or has an option if she wants
to play at some point h 6 to
prevent or to axis 5 and castling long or in
long rock straight as long as this
knight is on fingers because i never
knighted g5 there are times there are times there are
very interesting lines
by black unification g5 fast to
do g4 and try to put more pressure
on the point of 5 if exactly i
like it a lot  this plan is 65 direct of
course the long roque axis 5 direct play
axis 4 and while my king is on the
queenside it's hard to get to him
because white is
fully readying for an attack on the
kingside where he has more space and
they can't really  attacking the
queen's ship i like an's way of playing the
same way i like ezeiza firm 7
flexible to the ideas he can
put forward in action paikidze with white
now garza who doesn't have  go to touch
melamine place was cut simply
transposes to lines well known
by nazi paikidze europe
position one of the plans we had
talked about is 4 here it simply puts
pressure on the point where 5 is now
less desirable in prison not
because it can  opening the center that
can be a problem of course and 4 4 out of
4 and usually with short castling it
is not considered very good at the moment
I almost always have to calculate if I can
or cannot take knight where I want to
put that 4 because let's say knight 4
should always consider but
otherwise these types of structures with
df 4 files is hard to get rid of
in the pin
I always have let's say 14 5 or some
way to get my pawn back with some
gain now otherwise also
after knight 4 I'm not there either
completely forced
5 lair h 6 preparing that against the
efe field 45 as I was saying and
well also 4 and we see that the bishop
on b 7 always  counter the action
of g2 if it has its pros and cons of
4 now i like i like the plans
you say after 4 do h 6 5 and
put more pressure on 5 i don't like
taking the pawn directly if i had
that pin  in the middle if
white also has to look for something direct yes
because if I don't play knight 4 and how it
ended I develop and this knight in
f1
usually doesn't belong to the square
I like it almost with the code of moves
of 4 belongs to knight n4 obviously
she  so maybe he doesn't know that
this is always almost always healthy
street 4 because taking on 5 is
dangerous yes but it's coming but I don't
like it very much h 6 horses to one is with the
plan when the structure is in four
of 13-  2 no that it will be in short roque and
that there are plans like h4 the horse in hd
244 which was what we saw that the game
with the camera I don't like this immediate
h 6 as we had said I like h 4
that somehow prevents without the  move g
5 but  if I focus long and
anyway I play axis 5 in many cases you
are not very happy that the
achero file opens and even also that 5
direct at some point since the
knight on f3 would be retaking on g5 and
would fall on 52 son  very typical themes that
are here on the part of black
if the rock that I would say here is the most
natural inside that long at least
for me but as I said I think
that I cut also in that
perfectly playable position of course castling
short castling long to me  I really like
this type of position with black if that
's where his things are,
I think long almost let's say the
long block even preparing a g8 rook
and again this idea leaves 5 place
if it's as long as I expected yes
by anise
yes  I would think about long roque and well
what we have here it seems to me that three
could be a new candidate for
nazi paikidze to also try to
make a contract on the
queenside to make three and from four to
three  Of four it would seem to me an
excellent way to play yes
the bishop of two of four rooks of one
try to also if we stay there
very simple the receivers of
855 at once it seems to me that it is time to
take action clearly from white to 3 -  the
rein has to do it he doesn't have to
start trying to break on the
queenside though to be honest even
if he allows to play 394 I don't know what the
next move is because Tom suddenly makes 5
the knight for 6-5 if you take b5
right  the knight itself is that he is
uncomfortable yes but he does not open the h position 5 he
plays
yes although in a certain way
because if g5 I have the pace and here at
least I have this weakness that he can
attack
but what about rook 88 to threaten
g6 I don't like it so much g5 g6 I like it to
always keep taking no it doesn't seem like
a logical move to me because later when I
play let's say 3g 5g 6 it doesn't matter taking
taking I'm preparing
h5 h4 and at a glance black is
much faster  yes white yes
ricomá you say go 4 he took on c5 he resumed
with knight and I have no
problem instead putting the rook on f8 which
I imagine also in a certain way
prepares g5 the idea is he said 3g 5 took he
took the pressure that  exerts here it is
on knight envelope perhaps what it
says here is that it does not allow
playing ph three because for example rook for
queen for knight for 5 and I have
33 and that is why I do not imagine we will see that 5
because for that it was f  -8 or whatever,
look at the 5 different orgasms and
after three that we already have on the
board, I could play something simpler
like 8,
but hey, five or six seems to me
like the most logical city, if it's true,
that's very, very, very  true
alejandra we are here in the second
round in the second round of the
usa championship
in tiebreaker if it is the tiebreaker yes where
we already have a victory from there
we will see victory here we will see a
tiebreaker plus the armageddon the stage the
armageddon well they cannot move  because
there is still a lot of action here live and
direct from the city of saint louis
missouri it is already as it has been more or
less waiting for it ag-56 it has given white an
extra option i liked it more
4556 the reason is that we say after
g6  I'm taking I would take on white
yes that's why I liked it more than 675
in a certain way because I don't take I can't
even plan knight h 2
if with it with a head four it reinforces
the pawn here and if the kingside
closes that's where  black is attacking
because it would give me time for the
2004 bishop to see what I want to
do on the queenside and at
least white would not have many
problems in this variation to 13 5
knight 182 he would have to think about opening
directly  with
f 5f 6
5 56
what do you think here to
take knight but he has taken king
of 8 from me
it is not so strange for
he is not playing neither the end and the rook
but I am still
this idea of playing f5 seems a bit strange to me and
sacrifice the 6 p  problem not the first thing
that would come out is adriana mind does not fit
and h2 seems to me like the best move
here I do not like so much to open the
champion structure because six although
it destroys the defense of 6 in a certain way
it is not so easy to reach him because he
is there  so that two I need it in ge
I insist I did not like g5 more strength and it will be
more I left you and more game yes because of the
meter that 4 is a serious threat
efe five it is not so easy to make it
also new black fabrics ar what else
will we have because  after head 2 well
at the moment I am going to play game
4 a radical solution
the question of how you are going to defend yourself I
contracted 45 and now f 5 charges a lot
more if I take I can take as a knight and
I already have a point in 4
to defend but of course you have  reason
that after knight for queen here
maybe I have to watch out 18 and as
you are
saying anyway we are going to see f 5 either
first or after king bird 8 if the
opposition has its poison
also from the bla
I never have a bishop that can be this
dangerous one
that hits with 37 but is also
opening the white position both
sides I think they have their
8 bishop from 2 city quickly I am
a bit surprised by this
stable decision 2 profile because for me it was
more I am  the same first knight axis 3 and
place the knight near the square
at 4 bishop 2 and I don't have many
preparatory moves anymore I have to
play f 5f 6 I think they are basically the
same they are more it seems to me that they force the
move
efe efe 65 lo  same because I can take
with nfc 6 with the knight not in check 6 it
is very important as you are saying
that I directly have 15 8 and
capture four which seems very uncomfortable
for white not if I take the fise 8
the only move is give me  two only move
and if it really is like that because 4 and the
pressure on f 3 853
h 5 I am eating it bishop of 6 it
seems to me at the end of six it seemed to me at a
certain moment if move 24 again
then it helps white but not  both
and 8 I didn't like rook 85
because I understand the move but it seems
a bit slow to me if he wants to do f5 and everything
and to take a bishop and that the plan is
protected yes and if white
doesn't play b4 at this moment he doesn't have to play
24  but we explain why not go
ahead because if I don't play 4 I
play the efe file 8 and the g 7 and the
5 pawn I'm not seeing how I defend it I
think the idea of all 8 is there but I would
't have liked it much more than  adju
has played df 6
and out of four I don't have many
options not if I remain passive here but at
some point it is the end f 8 17 to win
the worst at least here after
minimum f8 bishop I can close the
queenside more or  less for example I
still have here but this knight suffers a
lot after the five he has a
good square so the decision here
is there are very typical issues here in this
type of position after 25 each
time 5 try to close the
white position then and give  and good if he
sacrifices  r a pawn and bad 94
seems to me a bad idea to take on b 4
without taking twice you have to accept
the sacrifice once until
the first pawn matures and either with the knight or
with the bishop 2 again sacrifice of the pp
where I was born to  the ipse and let's see if
his compensation sacrifice is going to be enough
to penetrate black's position
the kingside the kingside is
basically closed
now in action so trying to attack
what is going to be difficult is that this
horse will be seen soon in that 50
percent it is very late that it is a
sacrifice of worse but because if I
take each take each volume I already have it that
there is by 4 at the end
horse to see 4 we have it on screen
and horse by four in  time instead
of making a knight for d
[Music]
I'm also white
yes I'm already entering b 5 for example
5 I'm basically entering all sides
I think it hasn't generated any play there
but I'll take b 4 with the
knowledge that I  dragged  ro was falling very
strange
reported almost forced the body of 20
and here I have 77 well it doesn't always have 7
time later
I like knights of 6 for example no
no we were already a certain expression
black because I can always remove the
knight and start playing 4  the
kingside as we said completely
sealed i don't like what an is doing
and we would have to think at some
point to move 7 very effe region 6
try to see the position in some
way or another and maybe it's a good idea
7 where  let it be f 6 search against play
al somehow yes stop here at
least try to put the knight you will
need the diagonal at least it is
somewhat uncomfortable for me born
but this is not the current position
if it is good a move that seems
normal because this one today  it was
bothering me a lot because I like it
because it changes 357 this discovered in
this 5 that at least white if
this is something he wants to do I don't think so
but I would at least wait  that a
little for the think a little clear
before deciding what to do because I don't want to
change the knight that is so active
except with an exact check but on the other
hand knight of 5 allows this move of
queen b7 everything has to be here well more
or  less calculated of course for
here is the effective and practical one
sacrificing a pawn after
knight 5 by initiative if that is what we
are talking about not knight of 597
let's say king
7 king
where it is also more obvious because at
least for the threats in which I
leave  play
do I have to take the pp or not
5 is worrying the move that today in
1 to 7
brings trying to distract
maybe even stronger rooks by
77 I have this hacker
sorry where before
15 3
and this with our easy defend on
horseback by  the pin of everything and I
'm not so sure I would play knight and
five precisely I'm not seeing it
seems to me that if I play the 57 f3 falls it
begins to have certain threats that I
am not seeing how it is rejected  fast
by 6 by queen by ib3 we could think
if almost the only unique link between three and
we have nazi paikidze with 14 minutes and
any one with 17 minutes on the clock
because this game is important the
second game of the
and the second of two games that are  which
are in this tiebreaker where we will see if
nazi paikidze wins he would have chances to
go directly to armageddon alejandro
yes it
is the only way to win the championship
not to force the tiebreaker hernán and then
we will have from approximately
one ring efe five it seems to me the
move or ef 6 I'm sure but it's a
good one that we had given a long
time ago because black needs something on the
contrary he needs to activate his pieces
he can't stay to buy his crusaders he
has to do something in this
position
ef 6 we have it on him  board and i
want efe 6
and as we have seen black has
to open this position in some
way or another if he does not have much option left he
does it at least with  n an attack or at
least the open lines on the
squares on the queenside no clear
problems here I would say it doesn't matter
visually I like white better but
I'm not seeing something very obvious either for
example if I take the pawn he took the row
or  not even taking bishop c3 trying to
keep the position there I wasn't
totally sure of this position either
because if I take I take I have many
weaknesses but I was expecting the end
due to ef 6 I imagine that with the background it
is the end due to ef 6
the rook has  to go somewhere
because that exchange sacrifice is already
too much
and after degrees
we don't know how bishop of 4
bishop of 4 or knight
well knights 5 I was seeing what happens
if knight g3 because he takes 3 street 4 this
doesn't seem easy to me
4 no because  knight 4 and after removing the
nail I'm pregnant with the horse and if you
remove the horse
then you don't have that capacity not
good now 2 it seems to me that the
whole process is logical but
anyway  this the knight is going to enter 4
which is where it needs to be and this will
give white a slight advantage
still that is as safe as
coordinating to win but I still
like the position here if
I also like the position of  nazi
paikidze sometime in the
center-east 4 don't access the file 3a
knows him 5 i don't know try to coordinate the
white pieces to generate and break the
black position we have nazi paikidze
with 13 minutes on the clock and any one with
16 minutes on the clock  the second game of this
tiebreaker where we are playing for the
women's championship who will be the
next usa national champion
we have any one and nazi paikidze and place
your bets right place your
bets
alejandro what was your opinion about the
women's championship here in the usa
quite close  quite an
incredible performance by nazi paikidze and
by any wang well
go 8 of 11 8 of 11 and well
only not one lost well
yesterday  with sabina it was similar to me
that we are here not because he had a
point advantage over everyone else
with two rounds to play until a draw
with satoransky nazi beats tate and
then it becomes only half a
point he
loses against sabino and nazi wins against
in the end it seems to me that a logical move
as I have been mentioning five years ago
is always an idea with the idea of rook b1 if
I went for this move maybe I lik
d playing 74 first what I was
saying yes to control the gas s
uares no  in case of an exchange
of bishops well what suits
black much better and now with the finn 3
i like the nazi position even more
because no obvious plan was found
for black
maybe more ways to play knight 5
that at least after I go to 5
in this position I don't have a head 3 like
the other variant after taking well at
least the bishop continues to attack no and how about
coordinating for example the pieces
like bishop
5  65 that the 5 also appears quite
good I always have chances to
try to change the angels in
order f4
if it is bishops 5 to seem the most
logical move if bishop 5 tries even also
bishop 5 stays on horseback it is 5
by lan  and wan bishop 5 I liked it
because in a certain way it could be a
defender too
and directly attack white's
kingside I didn't like it at all it gave me rubbish of 8
rook of 8 pressing 3 I'm not
good even though I don't have anything tactical that
at least  I'm not seeing anything
overwhelming against knights but well
the exam every night is rubbish it's
defining the pawns I understand but
the knight of an h2s is out of the game
I would have loved to have here well and
four the difference in power between the
January knight
in h2 has  four, well, it's substantial, of
course, a tower of eight, I like it to
pressure white's position, just
as white is better, that's not going to
change, he has a healthier structure,
he can always play  garse 5 the attacks on
the queenside is true it is
clear that white is better but
after the chambermaid night 12 more than 4 I
like a little less the position that
we had here before rook of 8
by any one of  81
I don't see any tactics
without vat or anything like that
if one's tower will try to keep
white's position
here we are already getting into
trouble alejandro 11 minutes for nazi
paikidze 14 minutes for ni wang any one
winning the first round of this
tiebreaker
He says here they tell us about that horse of that
hour, a semi-horse, well
, yes, unlike 14,
but perhaps the only thing to solidify
here is his position and trying to
eventually seem to us 5 that he needs
so much if black
I think he really wants to play  seven
towers of seven to play tower of eight
also to tasks in one question good
work defending the on the second
if I like tower of 7 by any
defending the seventh and also
pre  pressing the column of not
pressing 3 yes I like it a lot a lot a lot I
like that any one and i want with the
very nice championship jacket
by the way yes yes from the championship and here
lady south and she sent us greetings she says good
afternoon Alejandro and Ivette  thank
you all for joining us thank you for
being here with us on this day
in these tiebreakers where we will already have
the usa championship the usa champion
as you see chubby and pretty yes very well
very well we have here thinking as well
what your next plan will be
this has to play some of the
towers in the second row because if not
I do not see how to coordinate them to make
some kind of threat they have to be
somewhat careful because let's say for I was born at
some point remove the f2 film who is going
to bother a lot of
course practically  one of the few pieces
he has well you can make black clear
no this position is very difficult for
black to play because the v8 king
is always more exposed to sa  crificios and
attacks we could even think of a
king at 8 not at some point but it is that
also king at 8 I stay in the coup the
column of a baxe I do not like
rea 8 at all
for example rook of 7
if the end f 2
because the bishop on g3 is bothering me
the key like that
yes I mean I mean rook of 7 for
example rook of 7 bishop efe 2 to
bother on g3 here I would be forced to
move
the king king to 8 king of 7 but he does not receive 7
I like it I stay there I don't know with some
blow na 7 after rook to 1 if
white still has here his 4
nazi paikidze sorry any one has three
minutes three minutes thinking about this one in
this position
in this position
and we have here hey but what  he laughed 8 I don't know
what he was saying
although I don't like the move so much
because well the blow is always
from the rook now he sees 13 for b 6 the friborg 6
all that
I don't know I'm not very convinced by the king there
but maybe it's him  better place but the
king
here we could even think 5 direct
oc 5 by white makes bishop
f2 and f3 which annoys the knight on 5
at least now he is winning
immediately
yes but after he feels like
he came on the knight I would like to
have him in the world be a little more o
13-8 by any one tower s 8
we have on the screen was not what I
was expecting
and c5 I am not 65 anymore at 16 55 don't believe
that they achieve from 55 tower to 1 and I am
entering at 6 not
about 6
and  well if that has been quite annoying
and I also have the 86 filler then
racing
after that 55 for example you already
start to see 4 toasts and the motion I
don't know and it cured it like that because of 4 I like it
because after taking at the end by  of
4 he pressed is 5 they impress at 74 m 1
nothing so it also seems
extremely logical because he takes it out of me
immediately the knight would be 7
for this shot again it seems to me something
solid logical
white still does not have much advantage
of taking him through the game  if
we are going to take we are going to trans  forming on
my horse a horse from a poor colt of
h2 and that it
becomes a royal steed that I
appear today seems to me to be the right move of course
if you are not particularly good when
playing classical chess in understanding which
is the worst piece you have  and improve it
if we are going to see if he can also do
a quick chess
if horse I know one that they hear was one
you have to take that other one as it says to
turn it into a tower 6 by part d
by Nazi paikidze good to be
the six attacked  who
started instead 6 I think it's true I don't know
why
because let's say that I defend this
profile doing five also seriously
makes five because I follow this 5 for
example if I play anything c 5 and if he
drinks here I have this note here or re for
times although here I can take doctor
take and take
probably this ending is very sad
for black not to take but I have no
queen 2 check but also the knight in
fact bothers me if I think the
best the best after  rook 6 instead
of rook 6 will be a better knight it was
another afternoon
to reintroduce him to the fight well at the
moment he is also threatened by
white queen 2 I like to press and the
column
yes queen 2 with the double attack on a 7
and b6 no  with force
at a certain moment 57 it seems to me that
watanabe 7 and i want plays with 10 minutes on
the clock and nazi paikidze with 8 minutes 8
minutes on the clock, my
friends, I
am attacking point 26 because I have
silhouettes and sometimes I don't know towers in 6  or
bishop of eight moves to defend the
direct threat must 6 and it is difficult to
survive this position with the
black pieces the rook is the end
of 8 are the only two moves that 98
considered also for threats
[Music]
so I set 3 but to  500 pesos
just 5 and for that reason maybe
four first
4 with the idea that at some point
the gift will make the gift uncomfortable
if a bit a position that is still very
sad for me the same, that is, the attack is
so strong that the black also with so
little against play it seems to me that this
suspension position is not the mistake of any
one was 5g six g6 to try to continue
there with the threats they continue 5 starts
I think the bad plays but the one I
don't like at all was this rook 8
we already have  we have on the board a
bishop of 8 for easy he had to withdraw
to try
to finally cover the film that three I think I will continue
with my plan
and that we get 3 917
21 for example
and I am already threatening to take in the seven
rooks of  instant win and even
because let's say axis 32 and i have grant
error and i'm
mating good threatening télam on b 7 and but
after everything else six queens out of 6 the
whole fight
because it could just buy me the
pin or healthy air of the kingdom but
more  of two
queen fingers to threaten rook to 8 and
queen by 7 at the end
you tell me in this position after
rook to 1 to 3
and I just eat in what I
was
because we are going to have rook to one
pr first  I'm going to set 3
if they seem very similar to each other
[Music]
tower 1 with the idea that I'm taking
directly and editors of 7 I have
some 3 games it's over it's going to end
and we'd go armageddon finally an
armageddon to determine
wow  impressive exciting and very,
very, very closed all
this is still
wow alejandro very closed we have this one
after him
tower 67 dean and on the board but
there he will not survive 2003 continuing with the
same threat yes
and I think you are thinking one because it
fixes  after the most obvious move in the world
no
and here on Black's part I can
have 15 trying to close the diagonal
that he made 55 ago it's the same as
strong it must be but if
his attack doesn't make 5 it's threatened until
66 is  a threat is sometimes a
3 bishop threat as a threat not
everything is being threatened for all
the dogs bam bam bam and there is no
way to defend the
black position up to here on  and everything we
are talking about is that there is no
counterplay there is simply no
counterplay that stops the same
no because it is so well roasted everything afflicts
3 up to 66 at some point to say
the queen of the bull for 7 that there is a lot
here is not totally lost  really
white's attack is free
and poor horse of h2 they put him to
defend himself so they need the attack he
is doing an excellent performance and
as the bodyguard the horse in h2
the colt is maybe real kursaal
completely fried and nazi paikidze with
7 minutes  6 seconds on the clock, the
same with 7 minutes 28 seconds on the
clock, we will see because the shot
by Nazi will be able to finish off this position and
thus go to an armageddon, staying in the
rapid games one by one one by one and
then we would go to majed  on how would
this be the armageddon alejandro I think it's
five minutes for white 4
for black 2 seconds of increment for
each
and there we are and the black of the black
he declared the winners in the event of a
draw, well, they are totally determined by
lottery, of course, and here leandro gado tells us,
go, go, all this goes on, candela,
candela, final barrier, we don't leave until
the end of the tournament, the maximum,
armageddon, and incredible
in '88 that we  It helps a lot and there are
so many doubts that I never set 36 depor
b 6
all the ones I have mentioned to ghana in
material to the film 3, maybe to rook 8
to try to make 15 after the
end that 3 bishop gt3 and without contracting to
make or there is  a blockade on the part but
no no I don't think this will work
there are a thousand ways to really win in the ones
that come to my mind for example I know from
b6
the variant here is 6 that today by
stay the bishop opened with 5 it
seems totally to me  clear winner because
I'm pregnant take here and dry 19
proposed malena 7 but simply 3
also 6 must win the film 3
after 5 for example in the black
suite take instead 6 as you mention
take in b 6 and everything is  or is taking a
lot of fluidity knight to see 6
bishop for 5 and life begins to be very
happy if that is totally won and
left basic material in French if
tournament 8 waiting here that I was born with
on matter knows that a
very good player is winning  strong and wants to have the
sensitivity that if that ends
well
if we already see their expressions of saying
there is something here yes here is something
interesting interesting and well we have
nazi paikidze with five rooks cc 1
rook according to what he does nothing
good
with was what  I was expecting it right
but again black you don't have against
games I see him wins
as well as a great dilemma but it
was just a little strange when I said
by black to try to
block the threat of g3 at some
point but also  I like about 5
is that at least he
the pawn
maybe he will get some counterfire maybe he
was considering more than 5 to
exchange queens
the endgame is not horrible it is not even material
e  he calls for
exchanging the queens
[Music]
quality I think not as I say
black's position is so bad that
even a move as inaccurate as you
are sure I still don't understand it I
should keep a decisive advantage
I don't understand why I'm sure  the
truth is I'm not
really making follow why doesn't he play fixed 3
for example 13 1 and I do whatever it is that
I do here our business that I don't
know what the 5 is going to do good what
we already have on the board
to take away the  diagonal or the threat of
feint 3 but I think it is
still a threat it does not have to be axis 3
if all these lines so after the
move a lot maybe it is that I get
praise that who knows black
is almost urgent totally
tied to  the defense as I say no
counterplay if after look at this
there is no counterplay
if here they comment is that black has
been totally useless
that if he says in he
says that it causes him a little d  e that the one about the
Indian attack is still working
today about the Indian attack worked
yesterday worked and will work tomorrow
it is always one of the ways of
playing chess here with white if not
what I would recommend as the only thing
among repertoires but it is always nice
As a surprise from time to time and
encouraged to continue, he is going to continue fighting
this game since, well, in the event of an
error or something, some draws are
enough to win the US
championship if all he has to do is
escape, but the estate  born has
everything to force armageddon it would not have
to be until a miracle not very lax and
more or less good luck good luck
here bishop g3 by nazi paikidze
already on the board on the board and
any one thinking about this position
we already entered  trouble dear friends
four minutes 46 for nazi paikidze with
4 minutes 34 seconds
still we are going to see an armageddon
that is very likely yes that is very
likely here in the campeo  born in the usa the
women's category where nothing is
written yet nothing nothing is written
says here they worry me like this he can't find a
way to win no he already found it
after three the black position is already melted
no yes
and well send a greeting to each one
of  thank you for being here with
us since the start of the day
several people have been here with
us since the start of the tournament
alejandro
since the start of the tournament and thanks for
joining us not because here we are
still not without determining absolutely
anything because well we are waiting for the
win like this in this game
finally incredible incredible we are going
to armageddon this has been hard fought hard
fought by both players really 8 out
of 11 possible 8 out of 11 possible
alejandra
for both players going to
who played tower 66
tower 6 alejandro
cuadra at least the same  it's a move but
this must be a good bull came
from one to two low just the
same position as  we have seen before
returning 1137 unique and I don't see why I don't
just know from b6 that seems
clean
to me it is the easiest way to win
here
and I don't know why the
easiest move appears to him let's see why it
is because  bc forbes is that today I tried 635
rook because it is the only one that pleases but not
with time in 5 and I don't have any
way to give a double attack
here that would be one with a way to create
counterplay I simply have a lot
of material of less than  6
the board 3 minutes 41 seconds for
nazi paikidze with 3 minutes 19 paran and
wang and he has to lower the field by 5 in
our position
because it could be taking worse
but why not if you rent 5
we are going to enter the variant that we have
seen  torres x 5 for 5 all
of you of quality of more than all of
joaquín's work we have everything to take it to
the region to the region we are going to go it's not
Alejandro's turn we will go to the almost
definitive margin it should not be a miracle
here for neither  one pair  not to go to the
tables
4 it will be the delay you don't know in this
game and if you see me at armageddon no delay is not
counted it will be I think about 15
intense minutes if you need to sort out
the pieces see who is going to play with
white and with was  let's remember that
only one game a game is not
played absolutely everything
and the time is five minutes plus two
seconds increment for white and
for black it is four minutes
four minutes plus two seconds
increment for black and in case of
a draw by  black is
declared the winner if the one with these
pieces doesn't and well he gives more than eight the
last move with the last trick he does
n't give up
nazi paikidze wins with the
white pieces a game where it least seemed
that here he had counterplay no if
I  he had against play, yes, and it
seems to me that he was not able to simply
specify it, we created it here with the
players, and this gets hot, there
we have a draw directly, we are going to
do it like one of the  good old days
is just for the dogs behind
the backs with the referee
and let's see who chooses that goal
also they don't choose but I don't know if they will have
to the point of the referee on the
left
eaton ibricic is the executive director
of the club leaves since  san luis is
talking to the commentators in english
i imagine and we will be here at the point of
seeing the draw to see what he thinks each player will have to do
good for me it is not obvious
who touched white like the one i feel
with black
who will have touched who white
that someone chose I do not know if it will give us
a little help to see what we are going to see who
touched white and who touched black to see
what
the little pennants who have
work not in the center do with it to see who
touches white and who touched black
who white  and those
of us who are important black tell us rest time
how long will we see each other here
alejandro we will return with
you in about 10 minutes but the
game will be d  e 15 ok you can't
miss armageddon the last game
to find out who is going to be the
national quarry of the united states championship
don't move and see you in a
while
[Music]
because the wind pushes the crickets
daddy because the sky  it is blue
because the sky is blue because it reflects
the light of the sea
to belong audio sacrifice like this for
8-7
followed by the horse
on May 5 5
[Music]
more and more boys are going to play
chess this is also going to lead to
you  ask more questions and you will surely
want to answer them in training with
dibise in ser 24 we are going to help you
learn how to reason how to think in
chess and thus you will be able to help your kid
I hope you have fun and I really
hope you in 324
[Music]
[  Music]
ah
[Music]
and
ii
ah
[Music]
and
ah
[Music]
[  Music]
ee
[Music]
[M  úsica]
and
[Music]
ah
what's up friends here we are back
in this exciting us championship
in the women's category where we have
here live and direct the
tiebreakers already in the game to  armageddon
with the live commentaries
of the great master alejandro ramírez and his
friend and vez garcía and what emotion we
are here at the end two games well
totally different and one where nobody
tries to attack sacrifices pawns and it does not work
out the same defends itself  he eats them
and wins and in the second game nazi
paikidze with a huge attack on the
queenside they simply manage to
penetrate any counterplay he had in
this position and then we go one by one
here the score between nazi paikidze and
han anyway we go directly here to the
screen to see what is going to happen in the
game white for nazi paikidze in
armageddon let's remember if I was born it starts with
four minutes
to neither do you have five not the other way around not the
eight minutes for blan  cas 2005 for
white but four minutes for black
12 seconds increment for both and
there they are and what happens if black
draws moving away black wins they win
anyway he just needs some draws some
draws to win the tournament the
united states championship and what
games will we have  here and I was even born
sitting thinking pensively ian just the
same way nervous so nervous
yes of course not my heart at a
thousand an hour the usa championship 2
failing everything playing armageddon from here
already after the two
rapid games if you have to break the  draw and
here we are waiting for you if we arrive
just minutes here to start the
game
who yes well if attention is felt
throughout the chess club
everyone waiting for this very important
result everything is defined here we know and
we will know in a few minutes
in about half an hour who will be the
champion of the united states here who will take seven
thousand dollars more is what is being
played not the difference  among the
prizes that we call the llama with the
game between animal and nazi paikidze and
less repeating it will be that we repeat the
idea I think he would make gloves very attached
to his openings and I think that yes,
we will go there and wash the revenge, yes, but
let's remember that he had one here  excellent
position or that if his coach
told him exactly how to play and how to
break he will have our mind position
but also maybe I was born now I know
the horse wheel and four we had already
seen before
but plus a slight delay in the
two-dimensional board  but we are
following the game of course we have the
same line the same line with the
same four and we have horse f1 hc equal
to equal and when and here we saw gh4 by
part d
on the same line we are repeating the
same line we saw in the second
round  of the quick games
god do it better gentlemen instead
of what you have seen before that was
five years ready cache 5 there is the novelty
of the horse game h 2  relative to
ah 5 and well all the same I can think of
the move rook g8 I can also think of
a move that 5 directly does not x 50
times 85 although this is 5 direct 5 and well
without waiting for a second not the
5 that is not a sacrifice  pawn
because I always have this problem with
the dog of 5 of course but I knew wrong
mentioned no yes but it is always something
that considers that the complex
but beautiful position would be logical to close the
center maybe they played h5 take advantage of the
knight on h2 to put it on axis 4
the next move the kingside breaks
are extremely important
let's see if he can do it this time
we are not in a very similar structure
and there goes h5 many times after
5 ago we could think of rook f 8 and f
5 repeating this type of  ideas to
break
in maine of course in this case the
knight will be on h2 I'm not going to play
here 4 which seems very doubtful to us and we
'll see what other ideas this cable g4 has now it's
going to be very good  n post
that's why we expected 38 by efe 8 because with
the very similar idea all the ugly collided
axis 4 this was what we were saying a
few games ago and now how am I going to
progress and iframe station of 8 and
preparing the efe move if you want
that  45 at some point to break
on the kingside he didn't make the
move last game and that cost him the
whole game on the part he never
broke what I remember he broke
just Nazis closed the position on
the kingside and attacked  I'm not a cue
came first and finished off the position
we'll see here we see live the armageddon
by the women's category the
tiebreaker here where it's five minutes
for white four minutes for ni
wang with two second increments if they have the
same it only needs a stable one
we have here
55 right rocks and we are going to see a certain
threat has the target here are because
as I said 6 is dangerous every time it is
definitely dangerous
we hope to think of tower 8 simply  e
to avoid knight jersey
rook 8 and in the same way make a bishop of
6 for 15 next try to get
this knight of 5 off of some
kind of exchanges I'm not ready to
play it's 6 because hey 6 but it took me
eight sinisters that's why I  it turned out
instead of rooks efe 8 it's better rook h 8
I have to take that 6
[Music]
65 and bishop for axis 2 and tomás de queen
46 hard take hard because
every time you feel the euro
from the current position
this structure is a bit  suspicious
for black it doesn't seem to you if I
would have to think if I have
ideas and how to break in 24 I would have to
think better about some maneuver like
cádiz and tico axis 5 at some point
immediately possible that
I didn't like all the changes so much because
knights follow 56 but it doesn't
remind us that I have this attack
the caches and I don't
take off noticeable from 8 either if at the end of
sisi knight g5
no no it doesn't fit that yes I don't
have to take off first but I thought of all
rre h 7
yes something like rook h7 and the veil
let's remember what they start with I was born one
minute too long but it's already two minutes too long
what is sitting here for anne the
same if nazi paikidze with three minutes
48 seconds any one with one minute 33
let's remember that it's only two second
increments it's no longer delay it's increment
in armageddon we have rook 8
by any one horse g6 by nazi
paikidze continuing here with the pressure
we would have to think we have to remove
the rook rook g8 seems pretty
healthy to me
doing  knight for h5 at some point
67 but don't take on the 6 in this
position
take on s we have already lost
65 45 on knight
yes of course the knight doesn't have any
squares very knight ef 6 am s 4 I have
am taking n 7 and  taking benefits
nothing more than 4 also the piece because
this is closed if horse efe six
check to each boss to this profession to
check give me efe four check and I am
making fall by the 7 calls that's why it is
called
776 and  I am entering the hoop queen by
bishop by rook by and with that
oh my god knights well 7
and for example we could think that there is
85 intermediate but I have queens 4 and
I am always threatening the hair of
85 we have 2 797 by an equal
both the seconds 34 seconds for any
one with nazi paikidze with 2 minutes 38
seconds just two minutes too ready
we will have the national capture of the usa
we will be able to finish off this position
there is no control
efe 5 wherever it is it is really expensive and it is
nervous 5 horsepower  and to consolidate his
piece he also has to make a rook of 8
try not to change the pieces of six
of six threatens both the queen
and the rook that we will have rook f8
try to change the 87 it seems
logical to me everything enters enter here it seems
very logical to me rooks rooks  porta efe eight
towers 7 even up to horse of six
horses six in the afternoon and they have
material two brooches 686 here my god 18
seconds for me one nazi paikidze with
two minutes  and we have rooks and they are on the
board by Nazi pay rook
66 rooks
777 over 666
and Nazi paikidze is thinking here what
we will have in this position I have 13 7
that went down the rook to the queen on
the diagonal rook c  737 s more
interesting but it is that everything wins here
everything wins horse of 6 is what
has happened well everything wins here everything wins
horses and 6 for horse b5 and take in
the 7 interesting also totally a
minute 24 11 minutes for nazi paikidze
with  white 10 seconds queen per h 6
also wins also wins
as you can see without any clear counterplay
for black in
addition to more for white total 4
because he plays legal
so he forces black to learn
wow
we have here thinking like this 56 towers efe
seven towers  efe seven also very hard
on the part of horses time the referee does not have
to call it
with an armageddon
finally happiness sectors to the
nazi international teacher paikidze from
born in georgia now the resident of
las vegas yes national champion of the usa
2016 and 2018 we already have here the
champions champion absolute champion where
we have sacha clan a nazi paikidze
as national champion of the united states
uaw congratulations to both and well what a
tournament what a tournament
this ass they gave us thanks for
joining us something  it was an excellent
event i think the best we had was
the performance of the carvana family i
thought it was incredible the fact that they
lost to the scouts but even
more impressive sans auckland they walk
with a +6 us champion nazi paikidze
they steal everything too close to any
one  in the end he manages to win armageddon and
we already have a national champion this
operation is a spectacular tournament
full of emotions full of
blonder's game of everything we had here and as
always it was a pleasure to have been here
sharing microphones with the
handsome and chubby grandmaster alejandro
ramírez  and above all a pleasure to be with
each one of you thanks for the support
thanks for the  messages and well thanks
for joining us we are saying goodbye
then here the transmission of Spain
of the absolute and women's championship of the USA
be subscribe for joining me
here in the studio and well it has been an
incredible event an incredibly
incredible event
that is without words in words words
incredible here  the usa championship
direct from the chess capital of the
world saint louis missouri and well as
always a pleasure to be here with all of
you a special thanks to
the chess club here in saint louis and well
a kiss and a hug to each one of
you and  thank you so much see you later
[Music]